It's almost Halloween. Time for kids of all ages to dress up as ghosts and monsters, watch scary movies and indulge in all things spooky and supernatural. The costumes and treats are just for fun, but surveys suggest that many people take ghosts quite seriously. One 2019 poll found that 20% of Americans believe that ghosts definitely exist, and another 25% say they probably exist. Many others believe in extrasensory perception, demons, space alien abysmal. reduction, near-death experiences, and all sorts of unearthly things. Where do these beliefs come from? What is behind their enduring appeal?
万圣节快到了。对于所有年龄段的孩子来说，这是打扮成鬼怪、看恐怖电影、沉浸在一切诡异和超自然事物中的时候。服装和糖果只是为了好玩，但调查表明，许多人对鬼魂相当认真。2019年的一项民意调查发现，20%的美国人相信鬼魂确实存在，另有25%的人说它们可能存在。许多其他人相信超感官知觉、恶魔、外太空异世界、濒死体验以及各种异界事物。这些信仰从何而来？它们持久吸引力的背后是什么？
And what explanations, psychological rather than supernatural, might underlie paranormal experiences? What does the science tell us? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Chris French, an emeritus professor of psychology and head of the anomalistic psychology research unit at Goldsmith's University of London. He studies the psychology of paranormal beliefs and anomalous experiences, looking for psychological
那么，可能构成超自然体验基础的心理学解释，而非超自然解释又是什么呢？科学告诉我们什么？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是克里斯·弗兰奇博士，他是伦敦大学金史密斯学院心理学荣休教授兼异常心理学研究单元负责人。他研究超自然信仰和异常体验的心理学，寻找各种现象的心理学
explanations for phenomena, including near-death experiences, ESP, and ghostly visitations, for example. He's written more than 150 journal articles and book chapters and several scholarly books. He also brings his research to the public by writing regular columns for the UK publications Skeptic and The Guardian, and he makes frequent appearances on TV, radio, and podcasts to offer a skeptic's perspective on paranormal experiences. Thank you for joining us, Dr. French. It's my pleasure. So I just mentioned that you're the head of the anomalistic psychology research unit at the University of London. What is anomalistic psychology? Yeah, I thought that might be the first question.
解释，例如濒死体验、超感官知觉和鬼魂造访。他撰写了150多篇期刊文章、书籍章节和几本学术著作。他还通过为英国出版物《怀疑论者》和《卫报》撰写定期专栏，将他的研究带给公众，并且他经常出现在电视、广播和播客中，为超自然体验提供怀疑论者的视角。谢谢你加入我们，弗兰奇博士。这是我的荣幸。我刚刚提到你是伦敦大学异常心理学研究单元的负责人。什么是异常心理学？是的，我猜这可能是第一个问题。
Anomalistic psychology is primarily focused upon trying to come up with and where possible put to the test, non-paranormal explanations, usually psychological explanations, for ostensibly paranormal experiences. So all the kinds of things you just mentioned there, people who think they've been abducted by aliens, people who think they've seen ghosts or that they have psychic powers and so on. our kind of working hypothesis, and I have to emphasize this is, this is all it is, but it's a working hypothesis, let's assume paranormal forces don't exist. Can we explain those claims in other terms? I would self-identify as a skeptic, certainly, but for me, an important part of skepticism is to always be open to the possibility that you might be wrong. New evidence might come along that makes you revise your opinion. For the time being, I would have to say, I don't, I don't believe that paranormal forces exist.
异常心理学主要集中于尝试提出并在可能的情况下对表面的超自然体验进行检验，给出非超自然解释，通常是心理学解释。所以你刚才提到的所有那些，比如认为自己被外星人劫持的人，认为自己看到鬼魂或拥有 psychic 力量的人等等。我们的一种工作假设，我必须强调这只是一个工作假设，但它是一个工作假设，让我们假设超自然力量不存在。我们能用其他术语来解释这些说法吗？我肯定会把自己定义为一个怀疑论者，但对我来说，怀疑论的一个重要部分是永远对你可能是错的可能性保持开放态度。新的证据可能会出现，让你修正你的意见。目前，我不得不说，我不，我不相信超自然力量存在。
So what are some of the psychological or cognitive factors that drive belief in the supernatural? People are very wedded to these beliefs. I think there's a whole host of different kinds of cognitive biases and weird experiences that people genuinely do have. I mean, I retired about a year ago, but before that, I used to teach a kind of 20-hour course on this stuff. So we'll try and boil it down into around 40 minutes or so. But basically, people do have genuinely weird experiences. Just to give one example, one of the ones that we're
那么，推动对超自然信仰的一些心理或认知因素是什么？人们对这些信仰非常执着。我认为这背后有一整串不同的认知偏差和人们确实会有的奇怪体验。我的意思是，我大约在一年前退休了，但在此之前，我曾经教授过一门大约20小时的相关课程。所以我们将尝试把它浓缩到大约40分钟左右。但基本上，人们确实会有真正奇怪的体验。仅举一个例子，我们最感兴趣的之一是
most interested in is a phenomenon called sleep paralysis, which is fairly common in its most basic form. But for a few people, they get very, very vivid hallucinations while they're having this experience as they lie there in their bed. And if you already, believe in ghosts or demons and so on, it's not surprising that they will sometimes opt for that as an explanation. So that's just one example. There's a whole range of cognitive biases that are also relevant to this topic. Again, just to give you a couple of examples, the very first systematic investigation of the unreliability of eyewitness testimony was actually carried out in the context of a fake seance back in the Victorian era. And so, you know, again, a lot of paranormal
一种被称为睡眠瘫痪的现象，它在其最基本的形式中相当普遍。但对于少数人来说，当他们在床上躺着经历这种体验时，他们会有非常非常生动的幻觉。如果你已经相信鬼魂或恶魔等等，那么他们有时会选择这个作为解释也就不足为奇了。这只是一个例子。还有一系列与这个主题相关的认知偏差。同样，仅举几个例子，历史上对目击证词不可靠性的第一次系统调查，实际上是在维多利亚时代的虚假降神会背景下进行的。所以，你知道，同样，很多超自然
claims are based on anecdotal evidence, and we've always got that problem of, well, how reliable is the account? Even if the person's being honest, they may be mistaken. And then when it comes to paranormal belief, again, there are a whole host of cognitive biases, problems that we have with probabilistic reasoning, for example. The list goes on and on, and I'm sure we can touch on some of them during our talk. I thought it was particularly interesting that you studied sleep paralysis. I mean, that's something that I experienced a great deal
的说法都是基于轶事证据，我们总是面临这样一个问题：这个叙述有多可靠？即使这个人很诚实，他也可能弄错了。然后当谈到超自然信仰时，同样，有大量的认知偏差，例如我们在概率推理方面存在的问题。这样的例子不胜枚举，我确信我们可以在我们的谈话中触及其中一些。我发现你研究睡眠瘫痪特别有趣。我的意思是，那是我在大学期间经历得很多
when I was a college student, and I think you've found that that's true among college students. Just to help people better understand, I mean, it's almost like you're conscious, but you're asleep. Can you explain a little more about what's happening? It is this kind of weird hybrid state
的事情，我想你发现这在大学生中也很普遍。为了帮助人们更好地理解，我的意思是，这几乎就像你是清醒的，但你又在睡觉。你能多解释一下发生了什么吗？这是一种奇怪的混合状态
between normal waking consciousness and dream consciousness. And as you say, students are particularly prone to it, interestingly. In terms of what I would call kind of basic sleep paralysis, which is really when you're half awake, half asleep, and you realise you can't move, it's a period of temporary paralysis.
介于正常清醒意识和梦境意识之间。正如你所说，有趣的是，学生尤其容易发生这种情况。就我所说的基础睡眠瘫痪而言，也就是当你半醒半睡，意识到自己动不了时，这是一个暂时瘫痪的时期。
And you just last a few seconds and you snap out of it and you maybe think that was a bit weird, but it doesn't really go any further than that. Interestingly, estimates vary hugely from one study to another across different countries, from literally a fraction of a percentage point up to 65, 70%. So clearly there's something weird going on there. And it's really about obviously how you ask the question, how you define it,
它只持续几秒钟，然后你就会脱离这种状态，你可能会觉得这有点奇怪，但并没有真正进一步发展。有趣的是，不同研究之间、不同国家的估计数字差异巨大，从字面上的零点几到65%、70%不等。所以很明显，那里发生了一些奇怪的事情。这实际上取决于你如何提问、如何定义它，
so how you present it to people. But the best estimate we have taking all those surveys into account, this is from an American friend of mine, Brian Sharpless, about 8% of the population will experience sleep paralysis, at least once in their life. But that's the general population. There are two groups that stand out in terms of having rates of more like 30%, and that is students and psychiatric patients, which is kind of quite interesting. It does make sense because if you have the underlying susceptibility, then you're much more likely to have an episode if your sleep pattern is disrupted. And two groups who have notoriously irregular sleep patterns would be students and psychiatric patients. Now, as I say, in its most basic form, it's no big deal. But for a smaller percentage of people, you can get a host of associated symptoms. You can get a sense of presence, feeling that there's
以及你如何把它呈现给人们。但考虑到所有这些调查，我们拥有的最佳估计——这是我的一个美国朋友布莱恩·夏普利斯提出的——大约8%的人口会在一生中经历至少一次睡眠瘫痪。但这只是普通人群。有两组人在发生率达到30%左右方面脱颖而出，那就是学生和精神病患者，这非常有趣。这确实说得通，因为如果你有潜在的易感性，那么如果你的睡眠模式被打乱，你经历发作的可能性就会大得多。众所周知，睡眠模式不规律的两组人就是学生和精神病患者。现在，正如我所说，在其最基本的形式下，这没什么大不了的。但对于较小比例的人来说，你会得到一系列相关的症状。你可能会有一种存在感，觉得有什么
something evil in the room with you. Even if you can't see it or hear it, you just know it's there. But sometimes people do actually hallucinate. So they might hear voices or footsteps or mechanical sounds. They might see lights moving around the room, or dark shadows, or even demons. and all witches, hags, all sorts of stuff. And also people often report a sense of pressure on the chest, difficulty breathing. Now, I can imagine if you get all this, it's not too surprising that people also report intense fear. But it's a kind of fear that's almost over and above the kind of fear that even people
邪恶的东西和你同处一室。即使你看不到它或听不到它，你也知道它就在那里。但有时人们确实会出现幻觉。所以他们可能会听到声音、脚步声或机械声。他们可能会看到在房间里移动的光线、黑影，甚至是恶魔、巫婆、老太婆，各种各样的东西。人们还经常报告胸部有压迫感、呼吸困难。现在，我可以想象，如果你经历了所有这些，人们也会报告强烈的恐惧也就不足为奇了。但这种恐惧几乎超越了那种即使在现实生活中
who in real life have been in life-threatening situations feel. They say, this is just orders of magnitude greater. And it's possible that it's the overactivation of the amygdala that's maybe causing that. So it's an integral part of the whole experience. But it's absolutely fascinating. I get sent lots of first-hand accounts. And again, I'm a skeptic. Usually the person who's sending me the account is a skeptic because they've figured out for themselves it's sleep paralysis, this thing that we know about.
经历过生命危险情况的人所感受到的恐惧。他们说，这简直是数量级的增长。这可能是杏仁核的过度激活导致的。所以它是整个体验不可分割的一部分。但它绝对迷人。我收到了很多第一手资料。再说一次，我是个怀疑论者。通常给我发账户的人也是个怀疑论者，因为他们自己已经弄清楚了这是睡眠瘫痪，是我们所知道的这种东西。
But the stories can still send a shiver down your spine. I don't think my episodes were ever that entertaining. Another area that you've studied is the idea motor effect, the fact that people can make movements that they're not consciously aware of. Oh, yes. And it's supposedly behind things like dousing for water or Ouija boards. And I found this especially interesting because when I was a kid, I was in junior high school. I had a friend. And she and I became obsessed with this Ouija board that I had and we would use it together.
但这些故事仍然能让人不寒而栗。我认为我的经历从来没有那么有趣。你研究的另一个领域是意念运动效应，即人们可以做出他们没有意识到的动作。哦，是的。它据说是水力探测或通灵板等事物背后的原因。我发现这特别有趣，因为当我还是个孩子的时候，我在初中。我有一个朋友。她和我对我有的一块通灵板着迷了，我们会一起使用它。
And it would spell out all kinds of words and it would send us on expeditions around the neighborhood. And it had just a whole series of personalities and rituals that we were supposed to go through. Now, I was not pushing that little table. And I still know where this woman is, and she swears to this day that she wasn't pushing the little table. So how does your work explain what may have been going on? Were we not in touch with, they called it Ouija Control? I mean, the board would tell me that there was a place called Ouija Control. That's a new one on me.
它会拼出各种各样的词，并会派我们去街区周围探险。它有一系列我们应该经历的个性和仪式。现在，我没有推那个小桌子。我仍然知道这个女人在哪里，直到今天她发誓她没有推那个小桌子。那么你的工作如何解释当时可能发生的事情呢？我们是否没有接触到他们所谓的“通灵板控制”？我的意思是，通灵板会告诉我有一个叫做“通灵板控制”的地方。这对我来说是个新鲜事。
I like that idea. No, I think we can be pretty sure that, in fact, between you, you were pushing the little Clive Shed, but you weren't consciously aware of it. And I totally know where you're coming from because as an undergraduate student, in my final year at Manchester University, I would go out on the Friday night and go to the pub and have a few drinks. I lived in a house with five other guys, and it was a regular thing that we'd do when we got back in. to entertain ourselves would play around with the Ouija board. And it does feel very much like, I'm not pushing this.
我喜欢这个主意。不，我想我们可以相当确定，实际上，你们两个在推那个小台子，只是你们没有意识到这一点。我完全理解你的感受，因为作为曼彻斯特大学最后一年的本科生，我会在周五晚上出去到酒吧喝几杯。我和另外五个男生合租一栋房子，当我们回来时，我们常做的一件事就是玩通灵板来消遣。感觉确实非常像，我没有推这个。
I'm not pushing this. It's interesting, again, one of the kind of nicest illustrations of the fact that this is what we call the idiotic motor effect where basically non-conscious muscular movements, that again, if we look back in the history of this, at the time of the heyday of seances back in the Victorian era, another craze that caught on, initially from America and then came over to Europe,
我没有推这个。有趣的是，这也是所谓的意念运动效应的一个极好的例证，基本上是非意识的肌肉运动，同样，如果我们回顾这段历史，在维多利亚时代降神会盛行的时候，另一种最初从美国流行起来然后传入欧洲的狂热，
was what's called table turning or table tilting. And this was, again, supposed to be a way of contacting the spirits where you take a small wooden table, the sitters would put their hands on the table top and they'd ask questions. And the table, on a good session,
被称为转桌或倾桌。这同样被认为是一种联系精神的方式，你拿一个小木桌，参与者把手放在桌面上并提出问题。在一次好的谈话中，
the table would be kind of shudder in response to the questions. On a very good session, It could even end up, it appeared that people were trying to chase the table around the room, trying to keep their hands in contact with it. All very, very exciting stuff. And this caught the attention of Sir Michael Faraday. And what I really like about this is that rather than just dismissing it, he thought, that's interesting, let's have a look at it.
桌子会随着问题而颤抖。在一次非常好的谈话中，它甚至可能最终表现得好像人们试图在房间里追逐桌子，试图让他们的手与它保持接触。所有这些都非常非常激动人心。这引起了迈克尔·法拉第爵士的注意。我真正喜欢的是，他没有直接驳回它，而是想，这很有趣，让我们来看看它。
So there are two possibilities here. One is that some external force, possibly a spirit, is moving the table, or in the case of the Ouija board, the planchette or the wine glass. or people are pushing the table without realizing it. And Faraday devised a number of ingenious experiments. I'll just mention one of them. Instead of having people put their hands directly on the tabletop, he had layers of waxed paper on the tabletop,
所以这里有两种可能性。一种是某种外部力量，可能是灵魂，在移动桌子，或者在通灵板的情况下，是记录板或酒杯；或者是人们在没有意识到自己在推桌子的情况下推了桌子。法拉第设计了许多巧妙的实验。我只提其中一个。他没有让人们直接把手放在桌面上，而是让桌面上铺着几层蜡纸，
and they put their hands on top of the layers of wax paper. Now, if you think about it, if the table moves to the right, if the table's moved on its own, the waxed papers, the hands will tend to drag behind a little bit, and the waxed papers would spread out to the left. If the hands are pushing the table, then the table will drag behind the hands a little bit, and the wax papers, the wax sheets would be pushed to the right. Well, you can guess what he actually found.
他们把手放在蜡纸层上面。现在想一想，如果桌子向右移动，如果桌子是自己移动的，蜡纸和手往往会稍微落后一点，蜡纸会向左展开。如果手在推桌子，那么桌子会稍微落后于手，蜡纸和蜡片会被推向右边。好吧，你可以猜到他实际发现了什么。
So even those people, these people were convinced they were not pushing the table around. Actually, they were. And again, yeah, we know from a number of different studies that that is almost certainly what's going on in these situations. What role does inattentional blindness play in having us kind of feel that there are supernatural things occurring around us? I think it's just one example of a situation where because we're not aware of the limitations of our cognitive system, we make various assumptions about how much information we take in, how accurate our memory is, etc., etc. So inattentional blindness refers to a situation where there might be a stimulus that you're actually looking directly at, but you don't see it, you don't perceive it. And the classic example of this is the famous invisible gorilla study, of course.
所以即使是那些人，这些人确信他们没有推桌子。实际上，他们确实推了。同样，是的，我们从许多不同的研究中知道，这几乎可以肯定是这些情况下发生的事情。无意视盲在让我们感觉周围有超自然事物发生时扮演了什么角色？我认为这只是一个情况的例子，因为我们没有意识到我们认知系统的局限性，我们对我们吸收了多少信息、我们的记忆有多准确等做出了各种假设。因此，无意视盲是指这样一种情况：可能有一个你正盯着看的刺激，但你没有看到它，你没有感知到它。当然，这方面的经典例子就是著名的隐形大猩猩研究。
Right. Me and my wife, who's also a psychologist, we kind of looked at this because she was doing lots of research into the topic of inattentional blindness. She contacted me one day to say, do you have a copy? of a scale that we could use to measure absorption. Absorption is the tendency that people have to become completely engrossed in what they're doing and to completely cut off the kind of outside world. So you know the kind of people who, when they read a book or watch a film, just get completely engrossed in it, and hence absorption. I did have such a scale. And my wife was basically interested in the issue of, well, you'd expect people who scored
对。我和我的妻子（她也是一名心理学家）研究过这个问题，因为她一直在做关于无意视盲主题的大量研究。有一天她联系我问，你有没有一份
highly on this measure to be maybe more susceptible to unintentional blindness. They might might not note, if they were in the gorilla study, for example, they might be the ones that because they were concentrating on the primary task to count the number of times the ball was thrown, they wouldn't see the gorilla. Which sounded sensible. Now, I knew that absorption correlates with paranormal belief and experience. So I thought, well, let's be interesting to look at all of this in one study. So that's what we did. We didn't use the guerrilla task. We used something that was conceptually similar. My wife programmed the computers
我们可以用来测量投入度的量表副本？投入度是人们倾向于完全沉浸在他们正在做的事情中并完全切断外部世界的倾向。所以你知道那种人在读书或看电影时，会完全沉浸其中，因此被称为投入度。我确实有这样一个量表。我妻子主要感兴趣的问题是，你可能会期望在这个指标上得分高的人可能对无意视盲更敏感。他们可能不会注意到，例如在看大猩猩的研究时，他们可能是那些因为专注于数球被投掷次数的主要任务而看不到大猩猩的人。听起来很合理。现在，我知道投入度与超自然信仰和体验相关。所以我想，把所有这些放在一项研究中会很有趣。所以这就是我们所做的。我们没有使用大猩猩任务。我们使用了一些概念上相似的东西。我妻子编写了计算机程序
so that you saw a display of white letters and black letters moving around the screen. The letters were kind of bounced off the edge of the screen as they moved around, and halfway through a big red cross moved slowly across the background. That was our gorilla. And the task was set up,
以便你在屏幕上看到移动的白色字母和黑色字母的显示。当它们四处移动时，字母从屏幕边缘反弹，大红十字架在背景中缓慢移动了一半。那是我们的大猩猩。任务的设定是，
so about half the people at the end of the task, if you said, did you notice anything unusual? or even more directly, did you see a red cross, about half the people who'd report they had seen it and half hadn't. What we found, as we predicted, was that the people who scored, the ones who didn't see the red cross, the inattentionally blind participants,
所以在任务结束时，如果你问大约一半的人“你注意到什么异常了吗？”或者更直接一点，“你看到红十字了吗？”，大约一半报告说看到了，另一半则没有。正如我们所预测的那样，我们的发现是那些得分较低的人，也就是没有看到红十字的、发生无意盲视的参与者，
scored higher overall on the absorption scale, also scored higher on paranormal belief and experience. And, you know, we replicated this effect in a second study, so it does seem to be a real effect. Now, bringing that back to kind of more real-life situations where people might think they've encountered a ghost. And again, it's maybe worth pointing out here that when people talk about ghostly encounters, I think that summons up an image of a translucent figure floating and coming through the wall and so on. But typically it's not that.
在吸收性量表上的总体得分更高，在超自然信念和经历上的得分也更高。而且，你知道的，我们在第二项研究中复制了这种效应，所以这似乎确实是一种真实存在的效应。现在，把这一点带回到人们可能认为自己遇到了鬼魂的更现实的生活情境中。同样，在这里指出这一点或许是值得的：当人们谈到鬼魂遭遇时，我认为这会让人联想到一个半透明的身影在漂浮、穿过墙壁等等的画面。但通常并不是那样。
It's more likely to be that people report that objects have been moved and they didn't know how they were moved. Or maybe, like we were talking about before, a sense of presence. or it's much more kind of subtle effects rather than a full apparitional experience. So someone who, for example, insists that they've had a paranormal experience because this is just a hypothetical example, you know, they were in a room and an object moved from one place to another and there was nobody else in the room, then, well, yeah, maybe you know, somebody else was in the room and they moved the object. You just didn't see them.
更常见的情况是，人们报告说物体移动了，而他们不知道它是怎么移动的。或者也许，就像我们之前讨论的那样，有一种存在感；或者是一些更微妙的效应，而不是完整的显灵体验。因此，举个例子，如果有人坚信他们有过超自然体验——因为这只是一个假设的例子，你知道的，他们在一个房间里，一个物产从一个地方移动到了另一个地方，而房间里没有别人，那么，好吧，也许吧，你知道的，房间里还有另一个人，他们移动了物体。你只是没看到他们。
Oh, but I'm sure I would have done. I would have done. You know, well, would you? People don't see a gorilla. And there have been so many variations on that basic study that we know that people don't often see things that they are sure they would see. So, again, just providing a mundane explanation for an ostensibly mysterious event. And for those few listeners who don't know the Invisible Gorilla study, can you just summarize that? Yes, certainly, yeah. This was a classic study in 1999 by Simons and Shabris.
哦，但我确信我会看到的。我一定会看到的。你知道的，真的会吗？人们连大猩猩都看不到。针对那项基础研究已经有了那么多的变体，以至于我们知道，人们往往看不到那些他们确信自己能看到的东西。所以，再次强调，这只是为表面上神秘的事件提供了一个世俗的解释。对于那些少数不知道“隐形大猩猩”研究的听众，你能简要总结一下吗？好的，没问题。这是西蒙斯和查布里斯在1999年的一项经典研究。
What they did was to show people a short video clip of two groups of people standing there, some in white shirts, some in black shirts, and each group were throwing a ball back in two to each other. And the task was to count the number of times that the people in the white shirts through the ball to each other ignore the people in the black shirts. And halfway through the video, somebody walks into the middle of the group in a gorilla suit, stands there beating their chest and then walks off. Now you think intuitively this is something that would be bound to capture your attention, even though it's not what you'd been asked to do, that you would notice it. About half the people who do that test don't see the gorilla. And it's a lovely example.
他们做的是向人们展示一段简短的视频片段，画面中有两群人站在那里，一些穿着白衬衫，一些穿着黑衬衫，每组人都在互相传球。任务是数一数穿白衬衫的人互相传球的次数，同时忽略穿黑衬衫的人。视频播到一半时，一个人穿着大猩猩服走入人群中间，站在那里捶胸顿足，然后走开。现在你会凭直觉认为，这绝对是那种会吸引你注意力的事情，即使这不是要求你去做的事情，你也应该会注意到它。大约一半做这个测试的人没有看到大猩猩。这是一个极好的例子。
I mean, again, they were shocked by the results themselves. They didn't expect that to get such a strong effect, but it's something that has been replicated to the nth degree. It's definitely real. He's got real implications, obviously, in real life. There's a lot of fatal accidents, of course, by people not seeing something that was right there. They were pointing their eyes at it. They just didn't register it. So it's generated a lot of further research.
我的意思是，同样，他们自己也对结果感到震惊。他们没想到会产生这么强烈的效果，但这是一种已经被复制到极致的现象。它绝对是真实的。显然，它在现实生活中有着现实的影响。当然，很多人遭遇致命事故，正是因为没有看到就在眼前的东西。他们的眼睛正对着它，只是大脑没有注册到。因此，这引发了大量后续研究。
We cover a broad range of psychology topics in this podcast, and I'm struck by the common themes that have come up in recent episodes. We've done episodes on conspiracy theories, superstitions, science denial, memory errors, and many similar issues that seem to emerge in terms of how our biases and other cognitive glitches can lead us astray. So do you see a connection between anomalistic psychology and research on these other topics like science denial and conspiracies? Oh, very much so, yeah. I mean, conspiracy theories, I've say in recent years, our research in terms of the areas that we've been actively researching, have been three main ones. One has been sleeper.
我们在本播客中涵盖了广泛的心理学主题，最近几集出现的共同主题让我深有感触。我们做过关于阴谋论、迷信、科学否定、记忆错误以及许多类似问题的节目，这些问题似乎在我们的偏见和其他认知小故障如何将我们引向歧途方面显现出来。那么，你认为异常心理学与关于科学否定和阴谋论等其他主题的研究之间有什么联系吗？哦，非常深刻，是的。我的意思是，阴谋论——我可以说近年来，就我们一直在积极研究的领域而言，主要有三个。一个是信件……
analysis. One has been false memories and the third has been belief in conspiracies. And there's a kind of, you know, they all kind of are linked to each other quite strongly. It's really, I mean, I'm fascinated by the whole topic of weird beliefs and where do they come from. There are many conspiracy theories that do have an explicitly paranormal angle to them. Obviously, they don't all have. But so many kind of links. between the kind of factors which influence whether or not people believe in conspiracies, whether or not people believe in the paranormal, the supernatural, alternative medicine. The list goes on.
分析。一个是错误记忆，第三个是对阴谋论的信仰。它们彼此之间有着非常强烈的某种联系。说实话，我对关于奇异信念的整个话题以及它们从何而来非常着迷。有许多阴谋论确实包含明确的超自然角度。显然，并不是所有阴谋论都这样。但是有那么多因素相互关联，这些因素影响着人们是否相信阴谋论、是否相信超自然现象、超自然能力或替代医学。这样的例子不胜枚举。
I'm an atheist, so I would even put religious beliefs into that category. These are all what I would classify as examples of magical thinking. And interestingly, they all tend to increase, our tendencies towards magical thinking, tend to increase at times of stress and uncertainty, and that seems to go across the board for all of them. But there are a lot of other parallels as well, which is fascinating. Now, you've done research to directly test whether paranormal claims might be for real. Can you talk about some of these studies?
我是一名无神论者，所以我甚至会把宗教信仰归入这一类。这些都是我归类为魔术思维（或称神奇思维）例子的事物。有趣的是，它们似乎都在增加——我们对魔术思维的倾向往往在压力和不确定时期有所增加，而且这似乎适用于所有这些倾向。但也有许多其他相似之处，这非常迷人。现在，你曾做过研究来直接检验超自然声称是否可能是真实的。你能谈谈其中一些研究吗？
So how do you test, for example, whether ESP exists? With respect to testing ESP, there are a number of established ways of doing it, One technique which I've never actually used personally, but one which is still something of a challenge for skeptics to explain away. I'm not convinced overall, otherwise I wouldn't be a skeptic. But the so-called Gansfeldt technique, this is based on the idea that if there is such a thing as ESP, then it's maybe a very weak signal, which is usually kind of drowned out by all the other processing that's going on in our brains at the time. Now, if there's anything in that idea, the things to do would be to try and dampen down the background activity so that the ESP signal, the telepathy signal, can come through. So what people do is you get a sender and a receiver, two people taking part in the study.
那么，你如何检验例如ESP（超感官知觉）是否存在呢？关于检验ESP，有许多既定的方法。有一种技术我个人实际上从未使用过，但它仍然是怀疑论者难以解释清楚的一个挑战。总的来说我并不确信，否则我就不会成为一个怀疑论者了。但所谓的“甘斯菲尔德技术”（Ganzfeld technique），其背后的想法是：如果真的存在ESP这种东西，那么它可能是一个非常微弱的信号，通常会被我们大脑中当时正在进行的所有其他处理过程所淹没。现在，如果这个观点有任何道理，那么要做的事情就是试图减弱背景活动，以便ESP信号、心灵感应信号能够穿透进来。所以人们的做法是找一个发送者和接收者，两个人参与研究。
The sender relaxes on a comfortable couch, wears headphones over which you play white noise. they have half ping pong balls over their eyes with cotton wool around them and maybe a red light bulb. So if they open their eyes, all they see is red. Basically, you're trying to kind of, it's like perceptual deprivation. And it's a very comfortable position to be in. And people typically report that when they're in that situation, they enter a very relaxed state. And their mind fills with imagery, you know, which is quite a common thing. You mean you're just lying there on your own couch.
发送者舒适地躺在沙发上，戴着播放白噪声的耳机，眼睛上盖着对半切开的乒乓球，周围塞满药棉，可能还有一个红色的灯泡。所以如果他们睁开眼睛，他们看到的只有红色。基本上，你是在试图——这就像是感知剥夺。这是一个非常舒适的姿势。人们通常报告说，当他们处于那种情况下时，他们会进入一种非常放松的状态。他们的脑海中充满了意象，你知道的，这是一种相当普遍的现象。意思是你就躺在自己的沙发上。
And the hope is that this is a kind of state that would be conducive to being able to receive these weak ESP signals. So at prearranged times, you have somebody in a distant location who randomly selects, it used to be kind of pictures that people would look at, often kind of art, postcards, that kind of thing. These days it tends to be video clips. You randomly select a set of typically four, let's say, video clips. and then randomly select one clip from within those, and that person, the sender, watches the video, and tries to telepathically transmit the information back to the receiver.
希望这种状态能够有利于接收这些微弱的ESP信号。因此，在预先安排的时间，你会让一个身处异地的人随机选择一些图片——过去通常是人们会看的图片，通常是某种艺术品、明信片之类的东西。如今，它往往是视频片段。你随机选择一组通常为四个的视频片段，然后从中随机选择一个片段，那个人——发送者——观看该视频，并试图将信息以心灵感应的方式传回给接收者。
There are variations on a theme, but essentially what would often happen is that the experimenter who is with the receiver would note down, they'd record everything that said, the experimenter who must not know what the target is themselves in case they give away any unconscious cues. Maybe at the end of the session, they'd go over it and say, you know, you said something about triangular shapes,
虽然主题会有所不同，但本质上通常发生的情况是，与接收者在一起的实验者会做笔记，他们会记录所说的一切。实验者自己绝不能知道目标是什么，以免泄露任何无意识的线索。也许在环节结束时，他们会回顾一下并说：“你知道的，你刚才提到了一些关于三角形形状的事情……”
could you just describe that a little bit more clearly, just to get all clarified and all recorded. But the clincher is when either the receiver or independent judges say what is the best match from the four available video clips to the imagery that the person was describing. Now, you would expect by chance people to get a hit rate of 25%, but it was claimed that people were getting hit rates of more like 33%. So not a massive effect, but statistically significant. That's one example.
“你能把那个描述得更清楚一点吗？”只是为了把所有内容都澄清并记录下来。但决定性的关键在于，当接收者或独立评判者指出，在四个可用的视频片段中，哪一个与此人所描述的意象最匹配。现在，按照偶然概率，人们的命中率应该为25%，但据称人们的命中率更接近于33%。所以这不是一个巨大的效应，但在统计学上是显著的。这是一个例子。
Now, there are issues, which again, we would probably need another three podcasts to talk about, which mean that, yeah, although I think the evidence there is quite interesting and worth taking seriously, which a lot of skeptics don't, and I think they should. I think they're kind of missing a trick there. There are studies like that. There are techniques like that where you can statistically analyze the results, where you can try your best to be as methodologically sound as you can, and not all of those results can be just dismissed by the skeptics.
现在，这里存在一些问题，同样，我们可能需要另外三个播客来讨论它们，这意味着，是的，尽管我认为那里的证据非常有趣，值得认真对待（许多怀疑论者不这么认为，而我认为他们应该这样做，我觉得他们在这方面漏掉了一些门道）。有这样的研究。有这样的技术，你可以对结果进行统计分析，你可以尽最大努力做到方法论上的健全，而并非所有这些结果都可以被怀疑论者轻易驳回。
That leads me to the idea of how your thinking has evolved over time, right? I mean, you were a believer in parapsychology when you were quite young, and then you changed your thinking. At one point, you thought parapsychology was a pseudoscience, but now you don't think that. What went through your, I mean, how did you reach this point? For me, kind of discovering the joys of skepticism, it was a very exciting time in my life, I have to say.
这让我想到了你的思想是如何随时间演变的，对吧？我的意思是，当你很年轻的时候，你曾是一个超心理学的信仰者，然后你改变了想法。有一段时间，你认为超心理学是一门伪科学，但现在你不再这么想了。你的内心经历了什么？我是说，你是如何达到这一点的？对我来说，发现怀疑主义的乐趣是我生命中非常激动人心的时刻，我必须这么说。
I'd always had an interest in these kind of things, not an overwhelming passion, but I'd always had an interest in kind of ghost stories and UFOs and just weird stuff generally. I like a lot of teenagers. And pretty much everything I'd read was very uncritical. It was very kind of pro-paranormal. And so why should I question it?
我对这类事情一直很感兴趣，虽然不是一种压倒性的热情，但我一直对鬼故事、UFO和各种奇异的事情普遍感兴趣。就像许多青少年一样。而且我读过的几乎所有东西都是毫无批判性的。它非常倾向于超自然。所以，我为什么要质疑它呢？
It was only when I was doing my PhD at Leicester University in a completely different area, nothing to do with anomalistic psychology. Someone recommended a book to me. It was by James Alcock. It was called Parasicology, Science or Magic. And that book kind of basically changed my life. life. You know, it opened up the doors. It was written by a social psychologist who was very informed on parapsychology, but was a skeptic. And he was presenting basically non-paranormal
直到我在莱斯特大学攻读博士学位时，研究一个完全不同的领域，与异常心理学毫无关系。有人向我推荐了一本书。那是詹姆斯·阿尔科克（James Alcock）写的。书名叫《超心理学：科学还是魔法》。这本书基本上改变了我的生活。你知道的，它为我打开了大门。它是由一位社会心理学家写的，他对超心理学非常了解，但他是一个怀疑论者。他基本上为一系列表面上是超自然体验的现象提出了……
accounts for a range of ostensibly paranormal experiences. And I found it all very, very kind of convincing and really interesting. And that's when I first kind of became a skeptic, so to speak. And I obviously then kind of realized that there were skeptical books out there. There were people like James Randi and Reheimen and all these other great people doing really interesting stuff. I shouldn't blame them for one aspect of this was that I initially had the impression that parapsychology was a pseudoscience, kind of no better than astrology in that respect, and various other kind of attitudes that all parapsychologists, were kind of incompetent. They didn't know how to design experiments or analyze data or any of these
非超自然的解释。我发现这一切非常非常有说服力，而且真的很有趣。也就是在那时，我第一次成为了一个怀疑论者，可以说是这样。很显然，我随后意识到市面上确实有怀疑论的书籍。有像詹姆斯·兰迪、雷海曼（Ray Hyman）以及所有其他那些做着真正有趣事情的伟大人物。我本不该责怪他们，其中的一个方面是，我最初给人的印象是超心理学是一门伪科学，在这方面它并不比占星术好多少，还有其他各种态度，认为所有的超心理学家都有点不称职。他们不知道如何设计实验、分析数据或做任何这些……
things. And, you know, various other kind of attitudes which I would now kind of say were, you know, too negative, too extreme. And it was only kind of over the years as I then gradually got to actually meet a number of real-life parapsychologists. I realized that, you know, this wasn't actually true. Again, one person that I would kind of particularly know here would be the late Professor Robert Morris, Bob Morris, up at Edinburgh, the Kursler Chair in Parasikosite. psychology, and his protege who is now the current Kirstler chair, Caroline Watt, who's a very good friend of mine, two people who were probably, certainly Bob, and maybe less so, Caroline, but Bob was definitely more of a believer than a skeptic, but he was very open to listen to what
事情。而且，你知道的，其他各种态度，我现在会说这些态度有点太负面、太极端了。直到多年后，我逐渐真正结识了许多现实生活中的超心理学家。我意识到，你知道的，这其实并不是真的。在这里，我可以特别提到的一个人是已故的罗伯特·莫里斯教授（Professor Robert Morris），即爱丁堡大学的库斯勒超心理学讲座教授（Kresge Chair，译者注：原文为Kursler，实际为Kresg Chair或Koestler Chair，这里按发音），以及他的门生、现任库斯勒讲座教授卡罗琳·瓦特（Caroline Watt），她是我非常好的朋友。他们两人——当然鲍勃肯定是，卡罗琳可能稍微少一点，但鲍勃绝对比起怀疑论者更像是一个信徒，但他非常愿意倾听……
skeptics had to say. I really like that kind of open-mindedness. And also, he had kind of, there were two strands to the work that was looking to see whether maybe you, be things like telepathy, precognition, etc., etc., really did exist. That was one strand, and that's probably what the major emphasis of that unit was about. But also a second strand, looking at why people might sometimes think they've had a paranormal experience when, in fact, they hadn't. I mean, his first PhD student was my good friend, Richard Wiseman, who, you know, is one of the kind of leading skeptics in terms of all this stuff as well.
怀疑论者要说的话。我真的很喜欢那种思想开放的态度。而且，他的工作有两条主线：一条是寻找诸如心灵感应、预知等现象是否真的存在。这是一条主线，这可能是该研究单位的主要重点。但还有第二条主线，即探讨为什么人们有时会认为自己有了超自然体验，而实际上并没有。我的意思是，他的第一个博士研究生是我的好朋友理查德·怀斯曼（Richard Wiseman），你知道的，他也是在所有这些事情上处于领先地位的怀疑论者之一。
And so, as I say, for many years, in my lectures, I would talk about pseudoscience generally, but when I talked about parapsychology, it was as pseudoscience, as I then saw it. And then I came across a paper where somebody had put this to the test empirically by looking at the typical kind of criticisms in terms of the criteria for pseudoscience that skeptics direct to parapsychology. and it's basically said, well, you know, are they true? By looking at three journals from kind of mainstream science, including the British Journal of Psychology, three journals from fringe sciences, including the Journal of Parasicology, and really on that basis, it didn't look like these were fair criticisms, the vast majority of them.
所以正如我所说，多年来在我的讲座中，我通常会谈论伪科学，但当我谈到超心理学时，我把它当作一门伪科学来谈，正如我当时所看到的那样。然后我偶然看到了一篇论文，有人通过观察怀疑论者针对超心理学的伪科学标准所提出的典型批评，对其进行了实证检验。它基本上是在说，好吧，你知道的，这些批评是真的吗？通过查阅来自主流科学的三本期刊（包括《英国心理学杂志》）以及来自边缘科学的三本期刊（包括《超心理学杂志》），实际上在此基础上，这些批评看起来并不公平，绝大多数都是如此。
And so on that basis, and ultimately, science is a method rather than a body of established facts. And you can look at any issue either scientifically or non-scientifically, but if you're looking at an issue scientifically, using methodological controls and statistical analysis and so on and so forth, why would you not say that's a science? And so, again, one final argument, people like myself, Richard Wiseman, James Randy, a whole host of other skeptics have sometimes directly tested paranormal claims, in which case we're doing parapsychology, and I would hope We're doing it scientifically. So parapsychology, at its best, I think, has to be described as a science.
因此，基于这一点，归根结底，科学是一种方法，而不是一组既定事实的事实集合。你可以用科学或非科学的方式来看待任何问题，但如果你正在用科学的方式看待一个问题，使用方法论控制和统计分析等等，你为什么不可以说这是一门科学呢？所以，还有一个最终的论点，像我本人、理查德·怀斯曼、詹姆斯·兰迪以及其他许多怀疑论者，有时会直接测试超自然的声称，在这种情况下我们就是在做超心理学，我希望我们是以科学的方式在做。因此，超心理学在其最佳状态下，我认为必须被描述为一门科学。
This is not a popular view among skeptics, I hasten to it. Our skeptics would disagree, but that's my position now. But essentially, I mean, if you design a study scientifically, you know, you could potentially potentially study anything, I mean, as long as you're following the prescribed method. But, you know, that raises another question in my mind. mind, which is that there have been studies that have been published in esteemed journals, peer-reviewed journals about parapsychology, and some of them have indicated an existence, and then some of them have been retracted. So, you know, why is that happening? Is that,
我得赶紧补充一句，这在怀疑论者当中并不是一个受欢迎的观点。其他怀疑论者会有所不同，但这就是我现在的立场。但本质上，我的意思是，如果你以科学的方式设计一项研究，你知道的，你几乎可以研究任何东西，我的意思是，只要你遵循规定的方法。但是，你知道的，这在我的脑海中引发了另一个问题，那就是有些研究已经发表在受人尊敬的期刊、同行评审期刊上，关于超心理学，其中一些研究表明其存在，然后其中一些又被撤回了。所以，你知道的，为什么会这样？是因为，
is that because we're not skeptical enough? I think it's, I mean, it is one of those, obviously, hugely controversial areas, and people, you know, emotions are high on both sides. I mean, one of the most recent episodes would be kind of Darrell Bem's controversial paper on precognition. And that was published in, I think it was 2011. Again, without going into all the details, Bem, who has obviously been around for many, many decades, very respected figure within psychology, but also unusually for a psychologist,
是因为我们不够怀疑吗？我认为这是——我的意思是，这显然是那些极具争议的领域之一，人们情绪高涨，双方皆是如此。我的意思是，最近的事件之一将是达尔·贝姆（Darrell Bem）关于预知的颇具争议的论文。那发表在，我想大概是2011年。同样，不深入所有细节，贝姆在心理学界已经活跃了数十年，是一个非常受人尊敬的人物，但对于心理学家来说很不寻常的是，
known to be very sympathetic towards parapsychology and paranormal claims. And he had already done this before in, With respect to the Gansfeld studies, rather than publishing in Parasicology journals, where the kind of mainstream science media wouldn't even bother to read the stuff, he'd made a point of trying to publish in really the top journals in psychology and succeeded on at least two occasions. And it's kind of interesting when somebody does that, because it raises all kinds of issues.
众所周知，他对超心理学和超自然声称非常同情。而且他以前在甘斯菲尔德研究方面就已经这样做过了，比起在超心理学期刊上发表（主流科学媒体甚至懒得去读那些东西），他特意试图在心理学顶级期刊上发表，并且在至少两次机会中成功了。当有人这样做时，这就变得很有趣，因为它引发了各种各样的问题。
just to kind of summarize, he published in the more recent study, the studies of precognition. There were nine experiments, over 1,000 participants in total. And basically, he was arguing that he had found pretty compelling evidence for the reality of people being able to sense future events before they happen pre-cognition. One of the very good things that he did, this paper I hasten to add, had been through, I think it was half a dozen different referees. It had done to the standard refereeing process. And at the end of the day,
简单总结一下，他在那项更新的研究中发表了关于预知的研究。总共有九个实验，超过一千名参与者。基本上，他认为自己找到了相当令人信服的证据，证明人们能够感知未来事件——即预知。他做得很好的一点是，这篇论文，我急需补充的是，经过了，我想大概有六个不同的审稿人的审阅。它完成了标准的审稿流程。最后，
the editor had felt they had no choice other than to publish, even though he probably knew that he was going to be a very controversial paper. One of the good things about what Ben did was to say he wanted other people to try and replicate the effects, and he would make his software available. We decided to chase up on that. we being in this case Richard Wiseman and Stuart Ritchie. I must admit we had a slightly ulterior motive here.
编辑觉得除了发表之外别无选择，尽管他可能知道这是一篇极具争议的论文。本所做的好事之一就是表示他希望其他人尝试复制这些实验效果，并且他会公开他的软件。我们决定跟进这件事。我们在这个案例中是指理查德·威斯曼（Richard Wiseman）和斯图尔特·里奇（Stuart Ritchie）。我必须承认，我们当时其实有点别的动机。
We didn't really expect to replicate the effects, but we did think this might be a relatively easy way to get a paper in a top journal. That was our hope. But anyway, it still took a lot of work. We each did an independent replication of Bem's experiment number nine. I can go with the details of what the experiment involved do you like, but just for the time being, I'll talk about the fact we didn't get the same
我们其实并没有期望复制出效果，但我们确实认为这可能是在顶级期刊上发表论文的一种相对简便的方法。那是我们的期望。不过，这仍然需要大量的工作。我们各自对本的第九个实验进行了独立的重复。如果你想听的话，我可以详细讲讲实验的内容，但目前为止，我先说说我们没有得到相同结果的事实。
results as Bem. We weren't surprised. We wrote it up. We sent it into the journal of personality and social psychology, and it was rejected without being sent out for peer review. And that's what really annoyed us, because this paper, Ben's paper had had huge coverage right around the world. So it's important whether these effects are real or not, and we had failed to replicate. But the attitude was, no, no, no, we don't publish replications. We were a bit cross about that, but we tried two other high-impact journals and got the same treatment. And again, we weren't saying, you know, you must publish this. We were saying, send it out for peer review. The British Journal of Psychology did send it out for peer review.
结果与本不同。我们并不感到意外。我们把报告写了出来，投给了《人格与社会心理学杂志》，结果在没有送去同行评议的情况下就被拒稿了。这正是让我们最恼火的地方，因为这篇论文，本的论文在全世界引起了巨大的报道。所以这些效应是否真实存在非常重要，而我们未能复制出来。但他们的态度是，不，不，不，我们不发表复制性研究。我们对此有点生气，但我们又尝试了其他两家高影响力期刊，受到了同样的对待。再说一次，我们并不是说，你必须发表这个。我们说的是，把它送去同行评议吧。《英国心理学杂志》确实把它送去同行评议了。
One referee really loved the paper. The other one had concerns. It wasn't too keen. And we could recognized from what the concerns that Rexrest were, we thought, we think we know who this referee is. We think it's a certain Darrell Bem. We asked him and he confirmed it was him. So clearly it's a conflict of interest there. How is that even possible that the editor would use him as a referee? That's what happened. So again, we said, well, you know, sent out to a third reviewer. Nope. Long story short, we published it in plus one. which, as you'll know, is an open access journal, which turned out to be a good move
一位审稿人非常喜欢这篇论文。另一位则有顾虑，不太热心。从这位审稿人提出的顾虑中，我们认出来了，心想，我们大概知道这位审稿人是谁了。我们觉得这人就是达里尔·本（Darrell Bem）。我们去问了他，他确认就是他自己。显然，这其中存在利益冲突。编辑怎么可能用他作为审稿人呢？事情就是这样。所以我们又说，好吧，能不能送给第三位审稿人？不行。简而言之，我们把它发表在了PLOS ONE上。你知道，这是一个开放获取期刊，结果证明这是一个明智的举动，
because at one point we were getting like a thousand views a day, which is amazing for a scientific paper. And it also fed into the ongoing discussions and debate about the replication crisis in psychology. Because this was a situation where I say the paper had gone through, the normal process of being reviewed and so on and so forth, and it had been published. Now, some people took the application,
因为一度我们每天能获得大约一千次浏览，这对于一篇科学论文来说相当惊人。这也融入了当时关于心理学复制危机的持续讨论和辩论中。因为这是一种情况，就像我说的，论文经历了正常的评审等流程，并且已经发表了。现在，有些人采取的看法是，
of, well, it can't possibly, the results can't possibly be true, therefore, how could this happen? There's something wrong with the whole process, the whole kind of scientific publication. Others were kind of more open-minded about whether possibly the results might be true or not. I think what it did, it made me think long and hard about the ways in which spurious results may end up being published and the kind of pressures that are on. And now, you know, the debate has kind of advanced to the extent that we all recognize that what we might call questionable research practice is not out and out fraud, much more subtle than that, but just kind of giving yourself the benefit of the doubt, knowing that you've got to get an effect that's just below that 0.05 level
嗯，这绝对不可能，结果绝不可能是真的，因此，怎么会发生这种事？整个流程，整个科学出版体系都有问题。其他人则对结果是否可能真实持更加开放的态度。我认为这件事让我深刻反思了虚假结果最终如何得以发表的方式，以及身上所承受的压力。现在，你知道，辩论已经进展到我们都承认的地步，我们所谓的有问题的研究实践并非彻头彻尾的欺诈，比那要微妙得多，只是某种程度上给自己留有余地，明知你需要得到一个刚好低于0.05显著性水平的效果，
of significance, otherwise the editors won't look at it. Then it kind of really highlighted how those issues can basically distort what ends up being published. And maybe particularly in what we would think of as the top journals, because they have a bias towards not only saying, well, we don't publish replications because they're not interesting enough, we don't publish negative findings. And, you know, so all the negative findings and all the kind of just boring old replications just don't see, ever see the light of day. Or usually in this case, as I say, we actually managed to kind of get it published.
否则编辑就不会看它。这就真正凸显了这些问题是如何从根本上扭曲最终发表的内容的。也许特别是在我们认为的顶级期刊中，因为它们有一种偏见，不仅体现在说，嗯，我们不发表复制性研究，因为它们不够有趣，我们也不发表否定性发现。然后，你知道，所有的否定性发现和所有那些无聊的旧复制研究就根本见不到天日。通常在这个案例中，正如我所说，我们实际上设法把它发表了。
Although that may be changing. I mean, I think there's more of a tendency to... Oh, I think it definitely is, and I think it's a healthy thing. I think I'm kind of... People talk about the kind of crisis in psychology. I just see it as a kind of healthy period of self-criticism. I must admit, I feel slightly guilty about it, because I can look back now and see papers that I have published in the past
尽管情况可能会改变。我的意思是，我认为有一种趋势……哦，我想它绝对是这样的，而且我认为这是一种健康的现象。我想我有点……人们谈论心理学领域的所谓危机。我只把它看作是一个健康的自我批评时期。我必须承认，我对此感到有些内疚，因为我现在回过头去，可以看到我过去发表的论文，
and think that probably wasn't a real effect. You know, things that I published and then tried to replicate myself and failed. And, you know, if you even try to send off a paper that's about these failed replications, even though it's your own work, you know, you're trying to say, no, I don't think that was real, after all, you can't get it published. Whereas now, I think, as you say, things do seem to be in the direction where that's going to be easier to do. So, yeah, so it's a bit, it's been a good outcome there, I think. So I know you do a lot of writing for the general public about the work that you do.
并认为那可能并不是一种真实的效应。你知道，那些我发表了后来自己试图复制却失败了的事情。而且，你知道，如果你甚至尝试去发表一篇关于这些失败复制的论文，哪怕那是你自己的工作，你知道，你想说，不，我终究认为那不是真的，你是无法发表它的。而现在，我想正如你所说，事情似乎正朝着更容易做到的方向发展。所以，是的，所以这是一个好结果，我想。所以我知道你为大众写了很多关于你所做的工作的文章。
And what is one lesson that you'd want people to take away from your research? I mean, I think what I just heard was part of it that science is evolving and that people should understand that we all need to keep an open mind. But, I mean, what would you say to just our average listener about what they should be thinking, say, about the paranormal, whether they believe in ghosts or think they've been inducted by aliens? What would your best advice be? I suppose, if maybe allow me kind of two or three, a little nuggets here rather than just one. I mean, one thing would be that I think it's best to base your beliefs about the way the universe operates on kind of solid empirical evidence, preferably from well-controlled studies, rather than personal experience. Now, for most people, personal experience is the gold standard. Even still in the legal system, eyewitness testimony is given far more credence than it should be, given what we know about the way memory works.
你希望人们从你的研究中汲取的一个教训是什么？我的意思是，我想我刚刚听到的一部分是科学在不断发展，人们应该明白我们都需要保持开放的心态。但是，我的意思是，对于我们的普通听众，关于他们应该如何看待超自然现象，无论是相信鬼魂还是认为自己被外星人绑架，你会对他们说些什么？你最好的建议是什么？我想，如果允许我提出两三个小建议，而不是只有一个。我的意思是，第一点是，我认为最好将你对宇宙运作方式的信仰建立在坚实的经验证据之上，最好是来自控制良好的研究，而不是个人经验。现在，对于大多数人来说，个人经验是金标准。甚至在法律系统中，目击者证词受到的信任也远超其应得水平，考虑到我们对记忆运作方式的了解。
So, you know, I think that would be one piece of advice that I think I'd like to pass on. And I think the other thing is kind of as you've hinted out there, that science is not. not a kind of an established body of facts. It's something that evolves. And scientists will sometimes change their minds on issues. And that's a good thing. You know, it's, it's, it's a pity we don't have kind of more politicians who are able to do that. But because of the way political systems work, it's political suicide to change your mind on an issue. I mean, that's how we've ended up with Brexit and maybe how you ended up with Trump. But let's not go.
所以，你知道，我想这将是我愿意传达的一个建议。我想另一件事就像你刚才暗示的那样，科学不是一种既定事实的集合。它是一个不断发展的事物。科学家有时会改变他们对问题的看法。这是一件好事。你知道，遗憾的是，我们没有更多能够做到这一点的政客。但由于政治系统的运作方式，在某个问题上改变看法是政治自杀。我的意思是，这就是我们如何最终导致脱欧，也许也是你如何导致特朗普上台的。但是我们不要去谈这个。
But, you know, I mean, there's, I actually respect people greatly who kind of stand up and say, actually, I've realized I was wrong about that. I think it's a good thing to do. Whereas, you know, there is still this tendency for people to see that as being kind of wishy-washy and you can't make your mind up. I think that's a mistake. Well, this has been a fascinating exchange. I really appreciate you joining us today, Dr. French.
但是，你知道，我的意思是，实际上我很尊敬那些站出来说，事实上，我意识到我在那件事上弄错了的人。我认为这是一件好事。然而，你知道，人们仍然有一种倾向，认为那是优柔寡断，是你无法下定决心。我认为这是一个错误。嗯，这是一次迷人的交流。非常感谢你今天加入我们，法国博士。
Thank you. I've enjoyed it. Thank you very much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spereg.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman.
谢谢。我很享受。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站www.spereg.org上找到《心理学谈话》过往的节目，也可以在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或你获取喜爱的播客的任何地方收听。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。本播客由莉·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。
Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condiion）。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。